hello readers
one of the wonderful things about
stories when they're given the room to
grow and expand is the idea of character
change or growth over time characters in
stories are just like real people they
have the capacity to change to make
mistakes to apologize to set things
right
to learn
when you read or when you interact with
any kind of fiction watch carefully for
how characters change over time
how do characters in a text interact
with each other
does the way a character reacts to
events change over the course of the
story
what's changed and why
one of my favorite pieces of fiction of
all time is avatar the last airbender
and while he isn't the main character i
think the character of prince zuko has
one of the best illustrations of
character change across the course of
the show so spoilers ahoy but zuko goes
from being an antagonist in the first
few seasons to officially joining the
protagonists the good guys in the final
season of the show
i appreciate how the creators of the
show map zuko's growth and change
because we can see him unlearning old
bad habits and taking on new more
productive ways of behaving as the show
progresses
he fundamentally changes as a person and
it's the result of a lot of hard work on
his part and a lot of love and patience
from the people who care about him
zuko is what is called a dynamic
character which is to say that he
changes throughout the story
this is the opposite of a static
character who does not change
there's a running gag in the avatar
series about this one hapless cabbage
merchant who keeps on showing up in
various cities only to have the
protagonists knock his cabbage cart over
again and again pretty much the only
thing he says in the course of the whole
show is his catchphrase my cabbages
he doesn't learn he doesn't grow he only
suffers
cabbage guy static character zuko
dynamic character many main characters
are dynamic but secondary and background
characters like the cabbage guy are
static
so what causes character change in
stories other people and events
let's take a look at an example from our
website oscar's musical odyssey oscar
begins the story by telling his friends
on the soccer team that he can't hang
out with him that night he's got to go
to the symphony with his parents
his teammates mock him and he feels bad
oscar was hesitant to say it out loud as
he knew exactly what would happen when
his friends found out where he was going
i have to go to the symphony tonight he
said quietly
the water in kevin's mouth exploded into
the air propelled by the laughter that
closely followed the symphony hey fellas
kevin exclaimed as his voice rose to
address everyone with an ear shot
guess where el capitan rico over here is
going he's gonna go sip tea and listen
to the symphony
instantly the other soccer guys joined
in mocking oscar i didn't know you had a
thing for old gringo music laughed
lorenzo what's next bro shattered one
watching the evening news in your
bathrobe what kind of soccer player goes
to the symphonies that javier oscar
sighed he knew this would happen
although he loved the camaraderie he had
with the guys on the soccer team the
amount of grief he was going to get over
a stupid night out with his parents was
going to be rough
very rough while oscar almost always
felt tight with this group this was
stirring up some feelings of isolation
within him
so this is how oscar reacts
he's hesitant he's embarrassed because
of how his friends feel about his
symphony plans they're not even his
plans his parents are making him go
good readers ask themselves how do
characters treat each other
oscar's friends think listening to
classical music is something for old
white dudes or fancy tea drinking nerds
but whatever it is it's definitely not
for soccer players
but then oscar attends the symphony and
he is bewitched by what he hears the
experience changes him so we can ask how
do events change how characters behave
well let's return to the text
on the way home oscar's mom said i know
this wasn't what you would have chosen
for tonight but i hope you enjoyed it
i thought it was great said oscar i had
no idea i was so wrapped up in what the
guys were saying about me that i didn't
give it a chance i bet they would love
this music he said
maybe said his dad but if they don't
does it matter
and that's when oscar understood
something
his whole identity didn't have to be
defined by only one or two things who he
was could be a mix an interwoven harmony
of many things
we can look to the text to provide
evidence of oscar's change he has this
moment of clarity in the car after the
symphony he realizes he doesn't have to
be either a soccer player or a guy who
enjoys symphonies he can be both at once
so when you're evaluating a character
ask yourself for specific choices that
characters make dialogue exchanges or
interactions with other characters or
responses to story events
compare similar events at different
points of the story does a character
react in the same way at the story's
beginning versus how they might react in
the middle or near the end of it if no
what's changed and why
if you can answer those questions
congratulations you've identified a
dynamic character
you can learn anything
dave it out
my cabbages